hey everybody it's Mike for your here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week now this week we're talking
about cmmc control
au.l2-3.3.6 provide audit record
reduction and Report generation to
support on-demand analysis and Reporting
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 10171 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so in cmmccontrol
au.l1-3.3.6 provide audit record
reduction and Report generation to
support on-demand analysis and Reporting
I'm going to call this the noise control
control all right if you've ever worked
with a seam solution before then you
know the first challenge of a system
like this is that out of the box they
just create massive levels of noise or
if they come with no rules at all then
they create no noise and you slowly sort
of turn up the volume ultimately that's
when a lot of confusion and alerts start
flooding your systems and all I can say
is yuck right the the boy that cried
wolf is not what you want as your
security system and that's exactly what
they turn into a lot of times so again
what an assessor is looking for here is
that there's some method of sort of
reducing all the audit record noise uh
that's going on with your system and
that you're actually getting reports on
things that are relevant you just have
to show them that so they have this
control to force you to actually make
sure that your seam system operates in a
way that reduces the noise and gives
relevant reporting and you'll need to be
prepared to demonstrate this so let's
check out what the assessors are looking
for how to make them happy on this one
now on this one we have two major things
that they're going to assess you on all
right so item number one is determine if
an audit record reduction capability
that supports on-demand analysis is
provided so one is there a capability
and is it provided in your system now
the easy answer to this one is you can
probably guess by this family of answers
is of course it is it's all built into
your seam system if you have one if
you're not familiar with the steam
system is it's probably time to give us
a call but it's basically a security
information and event management system
it ingests all your log file files it
parses them into actually useful alerts
and basically makes it so that you
actually do have monitoring on your
network as opposed to something like
antivirus which is very reactive this is
more proactive and real-time monitoring
now the second thing they're looking for
is they're going to say hey determine if
a report generation capability that
supports on-demand reporting is provided
so now we're talking about does your
seam system actually have an ability to
do on-demand report generation and of
course most good steam systems are going
to be able to do that but again not all
steam systems are created equal some
people are even sort of patching it
together creating one internally uh and
so again they want to really Define
exactly how this seam system is going to
work in order to provide you with useful
reports that you can actually do good
things with and keep your system safe
and be aware if there's something bad
about to happen now if you are
struggling to figure out this or any
other control uh there's good news for
you because at on call we work with
defense contractors just like you who
have had this defars nist itar and cmfc
compliant stuff dropped in their laps
like a seagull on a sunny day and we
teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps gray areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance as your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you if you're looking for more
help getting compliant our compliance
experts are always on call for you you
can visit cmmc compliance secrets.com or
check out the bio below for links to get
help right now if you love the content
that we're putting out here for you help
us out with a big thumbs up on that like
button or even better smash that
subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance centers roll it out until the
next compliance tip my friends stay safe
and secure out there and hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance I'll
see you on the next one
[Music]
thank you